I was once in the studio with a with an
artist a younger artist uh Tyler Creator
uh and we were talking about rapping as
you're old and I I was kind of telling
Tyler I was like man I just don't know
what like I'd rather write a book or
something at this point like I don't
know like you got to do it and I was
like why he was like because it shows us
what we can do when we get to that age
but to make it into a entertaining song
to where it's just not self-serving or
it's not just like there's a part of
entertaining someone else too I know I
joked about yeah having to go get a
colonoscopy and all this kind of stuff
and that's a real thing in my life but
to make that into a song or why not like
yeah of course but I got to make it into
a song that feels good as a song but
your track record as making people feel
good through song is track record is one
thing the right now is a whole another